The world's top climate-change denier may
be US President Donald Trump.
But around the world populists, including
the president of Brazil, are attacking what
they call the myth of global warming and forcing
environmentalists to defend accepted scientific
wisdom.
Germany is no exception.
Here the far-right populist AfD party argues
that humans don't cause climate change.
The most important thing is education and
people's common sense.
Despite relatively constant CO2 levels in
the past 10 years, there have been huge variations
in climate.
There is no cause and effect between CO2 and
temperatures.
The AfD wants to reverse Germany's ambitious
Renewable Energy Sources Act, cancel the country's
planned phase-out of coal power and take it
out of the 2015 Paris Agreement on climate.
That makes the co-leader of Germany's Green
Party see red.
The AfD is not only a far-right and sometimes
extremist party that isn't always committed
to our constitution -- it also doesn't stand
for freedom of research.
It doesn't acknowledge that on the environment
and in particular climate change we have evidence
accepted by scientists all over the world.
Instead it questions science itself."
The Greens say Germany's mainstream parties
should continue discussing climate protection
and not get stuck in quarrels with the AfD.
But that may be easier said than done.
The AfD and the Greens are vying to become
Germany's second most powerful political party,
and the climate is an issue where the populists
can take a clear stand against the mainstream.
Man-made climate change IS a problem for the
vast majority of Bundestag delegates.
But battles to set the environmental agenda
are raging on the national level in many places
around the world -- including ecologically
progressive Germany.